years before there was a disney plus i
was asked on cnbc
what i thought of this potential now
remember we covered netflix's slowing
growth rate and disney plus passing 100
million subscribers in their first 16
months of operation
on wednesday's show episode 1250 so i
was like hey i think i remember talking
about this on cnbc years ago
so i pulled some clips from cnbc from
2016 and 2017
five and four years ago and in march of
2016 i went on cnbc squawk alley which
is now called tech check
to talk about espn's new
direct-to-consumer video offering which
eventually became espn plus
and this was disney's first foray into
d2c
direct-to-consumer video streaming and i
was bullish on it from the start disney
stock was trading around 97
a share at that time with 160 billion
dollar market cap
it's almost double that today i probably
still undervalued i'd have to think that
through
but it seems undervalued to me but
anyway check out this two minute clip
from march of 2016.
i hate listening to myself from back in
the day but
let's have a listen here and i'll talk
to you about why what my thinking was at
the time
what is espn worth especially as they
are beginning to continue to spend
so much on rights they are losing
subscribers how do you value a business
like that
that has always been number one but
where the the ground is shifting pretty
dramatically underneath them
who they have to convince to get money
from is the big issue here right they
were negotiating previously with directv
cablevision time warner whoever now
they've got actually go to the consumer
and convince the consumer to give them
money directly
this will be a little bit scary for them
but look at hbo look at netflix look at
amazon
these companies are getting people to
pay direct it will actually be
huge for them when they have a database
of all these customers and then they can
slice and dice it right now they don't
have a database of
customers they don't have all these
credit cards on file they're going to
get
tens of millions of credit cards on file
and that's going to make them very
powerful this will be huge for espn
consumers are disgusted by the buffet
they want to go and they want to
have organic food and pick very specific
programming and once you do that you're
eating healthy
the buffet looks really disgusting but
thinking back to what iger said
on february 9th at the company's
earnings call where he said
we're not going to let the disrupters
disrupt us
yeah i think bob iger is doing a little
bit of a show here he's oh my god we're
going to lose control but actually i
think he's going to love this he's going
to love going to a direct consumer
and yeah everything is coming together
so if you look at the advertising pie
the internet now is roughly a third and
advertising on tv is still half
the internet just went right past
outdoor print and radio right we
demolished those three categories
now what's happening is what happens
with video and those two things are
actually merging into one
and when two things merge together and
you have the right
like bob iger owns everything in the
world marvel
star wars espn this guy owns all the
assets he is going to crush it disney is
a huge buy
they're going to have all the chips and
it doesn't matter what pipe they
distributed to they're going to get paid
it's just going to be this little you
know transition that's going to be hard
but he is inside laughing and thrilled
with this all right i have to give
myself credit i i do think bob weiger
was putting on a bit of a show there
for the case of the cable operators who
they have a tenuous relationship with
and they're going to go direct and they
don't want to lose the money from them
paying them for their content nor do
they want to lose the netflix money
remember netflix
was paying them for content at that time
that was those were big checks coming
into disney
and so this was going to be scary but
this is 3.5 years before disney plus
launched and it was super clear to me
like i i just look at myself and i
and having a family and having a
daughter or three daughters
at this time yeah i did have three
dollars at the time just thinking if i
could get the entire
disney library and all the star wars
library and the pixar library and the
marvel library in one place
that would be nirvana for me i don't
have to get dvds or
search on netflix versus cable
television where i'm gonna find those
movies here we are
disney is now at over a hundred millions
of subs and disney is a reformed company
and a company that is now their north
star is disney plus
literally that's their north star as a
company not parks not movies not
reselling ip
it is the subscriber base of disney plus
that's driving it a year and a half
later in august of 2017 i went back on
cnbc
to talk about disney's streaming
potential after they started pulling
their content off netflix which was a
super tell that was going to happen
here's the 90 second clip
of me describing how disney is going to
get tens of millions of users quickly
so disney with espn with marvel
star wars pixar and that whole
collection including the disney assets
of course the original movies
they have an incredible collection and
when they go direct it will be very easy
for them to get tens of millions of
people to subscribe
uh very easy though jason i'm wondering
you've got espn on the one hand but then
you've also got marvel
and lucasfilm and then you've got like
disney junior type stuff
it doesn't seem like all of that fits
under a single subscription
so do you have to sell them each
separately and do you
end up with subscription fatigue unless
there's something like
a cable bundle that authenticates for
all of them at once
no i think that disney is the one
company that could produce
a top three offering so they'll be right
up there with amazon
and netflix because if they were to just
give as an example
everybody who caught the tens of
millions of people who go to a theme
park if they gave each of them
a free three month or six month
subscription with their ticket purchase
they would easily get to tens of
millions of users if they took every
marvel comic book or
every star wars action figure or every
ticket sold to the next couple star wars
films and included a three month or six
month customer acquisition cost would be
zero dollars and so i believe they can
create tens of millions of subscribers
at the zero acquisition cost and
immediately be
the number two or three player in going
direct to consumers
and that's exactly what happens out of
the gate they became number three i
think behind netflix and
hbo now they're number two and i
actually will say right now it's pretty
clear they're going to eclipse netflix
uh very quickly
very quickly being like in under a
decade they didn't do that exact
strategy mine was like hey bundle it and
give people a bunch of coupons they
didn't have to they just charged 599 a
month they underpriced the product
that's another way to get people into a
new product is to
dramatically lower the price and that's
what they did 5.99 a month
when netflix was 12 at the time i think
or hbo and your cable bill was probably
in the 70 or 80
range they have the greatest trove of ip
ever assembled in the world star wars
marvel disney pixar you get the idea
if you think about all the reasons
they're gonna win number one
the trevor tr this treasure trove of ip
number two they have the money to hire
the greatest talent and that talent
wants to work with that ip
number three they dominate kids and if
you win the kids you win the household
of course who's gonna say no to their
kids
for ten dollars a month for this
incredible library
plus disney plus is only part of the
overall
product line and they have this bundling
potential that's
amazing i now have hulu and espn as part
of the disney bundle
and it's extraordinary hulu is amazing i
got rid of directv 18t
now because they screwed up my billing
and that was a godsend because once i
got onto hulu hulu is so
great on your apple tv or on your
desktop
or the ipad app it's 10 times better
than any other app i've ever used
for for live streaming of content like
cnbc or
watching the nba finals it's just
incredible
and the bundling potential is there for
20 bucks a month you can get two or
three of these services
and then you start thinking of the
upsell potential in the crossovers
new movies park tickets merchandise they
haven't even had that pop up yet
but at some point you're going to be in
that disney plus account
you're going to watch the mandalorian
and it's going to say would you want to
buy grogu
and you're going to say pre-order grogu
and you'll get that shipped to your
house to have your credit card on file
and boom i guess it was obvious wasn't
it all these things are obvious in
hindsight
it's important to be memorable and
sending gifts is a classy way
to create a great memory but give things
tough it could take forever
or you get sent to the wrong location
and it's never scaled properly until
now snack magic is a stress-free easy
and customizable way to delight
employees or customers snack magic uses
software to help recipients
build their own snack box and we're
using it now for our gifting you click
on the link
it says hey jason where this week in
startups you have this 50
100 250 credit what would you like and
then you start going through all these
amazing snacks and you get this
incredible gift box see here and i
love a bunch of different types of
gourmet items i'll take out a couple of
them you're gonna hear some crinkling
right now
you can get these air dried veggies and
i'm trying to eat more vegetables and
this seemed like a reasonable snack for
me
we would have these back and forth
discussions of what to get our customers
and what they like it's like oh they
don't eat chocolate oh they don't like
cheese oh this person's keto
this person's that this person's vegan
just send somebody
this snack magic link and you're done
and they get what they want
whether you want to delight one person
or a thousand snack
magic makes it easy send it to an
employer right now say thanks for the
hard work
here's a hundy here's 100 bucks you
could get 10 off if you use my offer
code twist
by going to snack magic dot com slash
twist very simple snack magic dot com
slash twist
10 off okay let's get back to this
amazing episode
you